hey what's up everyone my name is love
agarwal and i'm a data platform solution
engineer for ibm
data warehouses their prevalence across
enterprises has grown significantly
over the past 20 plus years but with
multiple modern advancements
the numerous options out there are now
much more complex
so let's talk about what an enterprise
data warehouse or
edw is so first and foremost there's
often confusion between
data lakes
and data warehouses
and even data
martz
so i like to think of a data warehouse
as being more
purpose specific than a data lake so
while a data lake is a great place to
dump
all sorts of raw structured and
unstructured data in a quick way to
clean and organize later
a data warehouse on the other hand is a
large collection of
organized and clean business data ready
to help an organization make decisions
and a data mart is like a subset of a
data warehouse
that's more specific to a particular
business domain
so for example you could have a finance
data mart
but for today let's focus on the data
warehouse so let's get rid of data lakes
and data marts
and make our data warehouse a little bit
bigger so the data warehouse serves as
the single source of truth for an
organization across
multiple knowledge domains and data in
the warehouse
comes from multiple different
source systems
and is transformed from raw data
to high quality data optimized for
analytics
via various different etl
or extract transform and load tools
so as i mentioned data in our data
that's in our source systems can be in
different types it could be
transactional systems it could be
relational databases
and they can cover a wide variety of
business domains
so the data could cover things like
customer data from our crms
we could have sales data
we could have data from our erp systems
we could even have supply chain data
and the list goes on and on right
so once data has been cleaned
transformed and
loaded into our data warehouse it's now
ready for us to expose
to our users
who can then start to take it and do
analytics and machine learning on these
data sets so
who are our users our users can be folks
like
business analysts
we can have data
scientists we could even have
data engineers
and these folks can now start
leveraging these data sets either using
the built-in
analytics tools in the data warehouse or
using
a variety of different
business intelligence or
predictive analytics and machine
learning
platforms okay
so now that we know what an enterprise
data warehouse is
let's talk about the different ways in
which it can be implemented
so three common ways in which a data
warehouse can be deployed
the first way is on-prem
now couple different ways in which an
on-prem data warehouse can be configured
we could have our data our data
warehouse running on
commodity hardware now this could be
set up and structured using either
mpp or massively parallel processing
architecture
where we just add more compute nodes as
our workload grows
or using smp
or symmetric symmetric multi-processing
architecture
where typically we have a tightly
coupled multi-cpu system
that shares resources from one common
operating system
now the other way is through a
purpose-built
appliance format
now this is typically an integrated
stack
of cpu memory storage software
all purpose built and optimized for a
data warehouse workload from
a single vendor so what are some of the
benefits of having an on-prem data
warehouse
well first you get to maintain complete
control
over the entire tech stack right
second you can leverage your
local network speeds and perhaps avoid
some bandwidth challenges
typically associated with the cloud you
can also
leverage high availability
and we can maintain strict governance
and regulatory compliance but on the
other hand
an on-prem data warehouse does come with
an upfront investment
and the need for ongoing support and
maintenance
now the other way in which your data
warehouse can be deployed
is through a cloud-based data warehouse
where our data warehouse is delivered as
a managed
sas offering via
the multiple public cloud providers so
moving data warehouses to the cloud uh
is is
uh the next frontier for a lot of
enterprises and for valid reasons
right some of the benefits include being
able to free up resources
to focus on other high-value analytics
tasks
right instead of just managing systems
another benefit can also be the ability
to scale
easily right because we don't have to go
out and procure new hardware
and we we get to leverage automatic
upgrades right
now on the other hand oftentimes a
cloud-based data warehouse
can take a performance hit due to how
it's fine-tuned for that specific
workload
and there can be some unanticipated high
costs
due to how cloud data warehouses scale
okay the third option is actually a
hybrid approach
so this takes the best of on-prem and
cloud and brings them together
and a lot of enterprises choose to run
both their on-prem and cloud data
warehouses in conjunction
and this can be done for a couple
different reasons
so one benefit can be that this allows
us to explore
new use cases right so as an enterprise
we may have certain
data sources that were born in the cloud
so it can be beneficial to start
leveraging a cloud
data warehouse for analytics against
those use cases
while still maintaining their
mission-critical workloads on-prem
right another benefit can be
for a disaster recovery
and backup scenario
this is where we use both our
environments in conjunction for dr and
backup reasons
so if we take a step back we can see
that you know we've barely started to
scratch the surface
of enterprise data warehouses and how
they fit into
an overall enterprise architecture but i
hope this video has given us a good idea
of how data warehouses fit in and what
they're used for
thank you if you have any questions
please drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget if you want to learn
more about any of the ibm data solutions
we've discussed today
please feel free to check out the link
below